[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y lima y continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
el gobierno griego declaró tres días de
duelo tras el naufragio que dejó 79
migrantes fallecidos se estima que entre
400 y 750 personas iban en la
embarcación que había partido desde las
costas libias el hecho ocurre el mismo
día en que acnur alertó que el mundo
alcanzó el récord de 110 millones de
desplazados y refugiados en 2022
en Guatemala el periodista José Rubén
Zamora uno de los principales críticos
del gobierno de Alejandro yamatei fue
condenado este miércoles a seis años de
prisión por lavado de dinero en un
proceso señalado de estar plagado de
irregularidades analizamos en esta
emisión
El Congreso de El Salvador aprobó la
reducción del número de municipios que
pasará de 262 a 44 a partir de mayo de
2024 según el presidente de la asamblea
de la reducción supone un ahorro de 250
millones de dólares anuales para pero
para la oposición es una táctica del
gobierno de bukele para mantener el
control territorial
[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzamos en Grecia porque ascendió al
menos 79 la cifra de migrantes muertos
por el naufragio de una embarcación que
había partido desde Libia y que se
hundió en el mar abierto frente a las
costas griegas las víctimas pueden ser
más pues estima que había entre 400 y
750 pasajeros y sólo 104 han sido
rescatados algunas marchas fueron
convocadas en Grecia para pedir que se
tomen medidas que garanticen el tránsito
seguro de migrantes y refugiados al
tiempo que el gobierno del heno decretó
tres días de luto el informe es de
Andrés triviño
ha sido catalogado como el naufragio más
mortífero en lo que va del año las
autoridades de Grecia informaron sobre
el hundimiento de un barco pesquero en
el mar jónico se cree que entre 400 y
750 personas de distintas nacionalidades
iban a votar pragma
de hecho es una situación Trágica una
situación muy difícil con una gran
cantidad de náufragos una cantidad que
creo que no hemos enfrentado en el
pasado en tal medida ni volumen
según medios griegos la guardia costera
de ese país detectó la embarcación y
ofreció ayuda pero sus tripulantes la
rechazaron unas horas más tarde se volcó
y se hundió al parecer casi todos los
ocupantes eran hombres jóvenes alrededor
de los 20 años la mayoría provenientes
de Egipto Siria y Pakistán
la embarcación partió desde la ciudad
Libia de tobrok y tenía como Destino
final Italia pero se accidentó a unos
kilómetros de la ciudad costera de pilos
al sur de Grecia hasta allí fueron
trasladados los sobrevivientes Quienes
fueron repartidos entre hospitales y
refugios
la presidenta de Grecia hizo presencia
en la zona y la ONU se refirió a lo
ocurrido
la única forma en que obtendremos camino
seguros la única forma en que evitaremos
que las personas emprendan estos viajes
peligrosos la única forma en que
Sacaremos a las bandas criminales de
esta ecuación es si solo los países de
origen los países de tránsito y los
países de destino trabajo juntos Grecia
es una de las principales rutas de
entrada a la Unión Europea para
migrantes y refugiados creando un
mercado ilegal que cada vez es más
grande y difícil de controlar este
naufragio ocurre Precisamente en el día
en que el alto comisionado de Naciones
Unidas para los refugiados publicó una
alarmante informe en el que alerta que
el mundo alcanzó el récord de 110
millones de personas desplazadas y
refugiadas en 2022 según el organismo
los recientes combates en Sudán la
invasión rusa de Ucrania y la crisis
humanitaria en Afganistán agravan la
situación dábamos el informe
un informe preocupante nunca el número
de refugiados y de desplazados en el
mundo había sido tan elevado la ONU ha
hecho las cuentas una cifra récord de
110 millones de personas se han visto
obligadas a abandonar sus hogares una
cifra que no deja de aumentar
Recuerda que hace unos años Incluso el
año pasado anunciamos por primera vez
que habíamos superado los 100 millones
de desplazados bien esa cifra ha
aumentado un 10%
es una verdadera acusación contra el
estado de nuestro mundo si se me permite
decirlo tener y anunciar eso la razón de
este fuerte aumento los conflictos en
particular el que afecta a Sudán los
enfrentamientos entre el ejército y los
paramilitares han disparado el número de
desplazados en las últimas semanas
la guerra en Ucrania también ha
contribuido a este aumento récord otra
lección de las Naciones Unidas tres
cuartos de estos refugiados huyen a
países de bajos ingresos esto contradice
la idea a menudo difundida sobre todo en
Europa de migrantes que abrumarían a las
naciones ricas
el alto comisionado para los refugiados
ha lanzado un mensaje a los dirigentes
políticos
a menudo oímos la opinión pública está
harta no podemos aceptar a nadie más
gobernar también significa convencer a
la opinión pública de que ciertas
personas necesitan protección
internacional y de que hay que hacer
todo lo posible para conseguirlo
acnur también ha reconocido que no
dispone de los medios necesarios para
ayudar a esos millones de refugiados
vamos a Guatemala el periodista José
Rubén Zamora fundador del medio del
periódico fue condenado a seis años de
prisión por lavado de dinero el caso ha
sido señalado de tener políticas ya que
el medio publicó múltiples
investigaciones sobre corrupción en el
gobierno de Alejandro yamatei de hecho
forzaron a que el periódico cerrara y
otros ocho periodistas están
investigados para analizar esta
información conectamos con Evelyn Blanc
directora y fundadora del centro civitas
Guatemala y periodista del colectivo no
nos callarán bienvenida a France 24 uno
de los hechos que llamó la atención en
la audiencia de condena fue que a José
Rubén Zamora ni siquiera le permitieron
leer su discurso de defensa A qué se
debió esta decisión
bueno el tribunal fundamentó su decisión
en que la oportunidad era para hacer una
petición especial y que los escritos del
señor Zamora estaban rebasando ese
ámbito Pero esto en realidad no fue lo
más grave que sucedió hoy lo más grave
que sucedió hoy es que el señor Zamora
fue condenado a seis años de prisión
inconmutable por un delito que nunca se
produjo porque para verse producido el
delito el dinero en cuestión los
trescientos mil quetzales debieron haber
sido depositados en un banco o sea Esa
es la manera en Cómo se blanquea o se
lava el dinero ese dinero nunca fue
depositado en un banco y aún así se le
condenó a seis años de prisión y aparte
el tribunal valoró pruebas obtenidas de
manera ilegal y algunas de las cuales ni
siquiera estaban relacionadas con el
presunto plazo en el cual se cometió
este presunto delito
bueno José Rubén Zamora ha sido descrito
en numerosas ocasiones como un crítico
del gobierno de Alejandro yamatei Cuál
ha sido la importancia de su papel a
nivel periodístico
el periódico en realidad no ha sido solo
crítico de Alejandro y el periódico ha
sido crítico de todos los gobiernos en
realidad ha sido un medio que ha
aportado muchísimo muchísima información
con base en en investigación Y en este
sentido ha sido considerado un medio muy
relevante en Guatemala en términos de
hacer comprender a la ciudadanía el
grado de corrupción que ha asistido a
todos estos gobiernos lo sucedido al
Señor Zamora se enmarca además en una
estrategia de criminalización que es
generalizada que lo que pretende
silenciar a la a la prensa para que
prosiga su camino Este modelo
autoritario que se está implantando en
el país bueno justamente usted lo estaba
mencionando Cuál es la radiografía que
haría o que se puede hacer de la
situación actual de la libertad de
prensa en Guatemala
sumamente preocupante porque
nunca Guatemala ha tenido una libertad
de prensa
no voy a decir absoluta porque no existe
tal vez en ningún país pero bastante
decente porque nunca ha sido digamos
nunca ha habido un gobierno o un régimen
de democracia plena pero lo grave ahora
es que sean los operadores de Justicia
del sistema de Justicia quienes están
criminalizando O sea quien Quienes
deberían estar garantizándonos
nuestra libertad de expresión nuestra
libertad de prensa son quienes nos están
criminalizando son quienes están
ejecutando esta estrategia eso es lo
realmente preocupante señora Blanca
usted muchas gracias por su análisis y
por compartirlo con nosotros en France
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes nosotros
continuamos El Salvador reducirá
drásticamente la la cantidad de
municipios la asamblea dominada por
partidos afines al presidente nayib
bukele aprobó el proyecto de ley que
obliga a pasar de 262 municipios a 44 la
medida aplicará desde 2024 pero desde ya
los críticos señalan que beneficiará
electoralmente a bukele quien también
logró reducir los escaños de
legislativos Alba Santana tiene la
historia
lo prometió ya pasado a la acción tras
la aprobación de la asamblea el gobierno
de nayib bukele promulgó una ley este
miércoles
queda aprobada la ley en términos
generales
la ley especial de reestructuración
municipal que reducirá los 262
municipios del país a tan solo 44 un
movimiento impulsado por bukele y su
partido nuevas ideas bajo el argumento
de reducir los gastos estatales y
combatir la corrupción
he firmado y autorizado que se convierta
en ley la total reorganización de la
división político administrativa de El
Salvador historia no obstante la
oposición de este movimiento como un
nuevo abuso de poder del mandatario y lo
acusa de querer sacar rédito electoral
centralizar El Poder y quitar autonomía
a los municipios qué obtiene la el
gobierno en beneficio digamos o por qué
quiere hacer esto advertimos que los los
centros las concentraciones de población
se están produciendo de una manera que
pueda provocarle mayores réditos
electorales al gobierno durante su
discurso de cuatro años de gobierno
bukele prometió una reducción del estado
por lo que hace apenas una semana redujo
el número de diputados de 84 a 60 tras
su aprobación la nueva ley se aplicará a
partir de mayo de 2024 cuando muchos
municipios pasarán a ser distritos
la fundación cluny para la Justicia
apelado del principio de jurisdicción
universal para tratar de que un tribunal
argentino investigue y sancione a las
fuerzas de seguridad de Venezuela por lo
que ha denunciado como crímenes de lesa
humanidad que no constituyen casos
aislados sino una política de estado
humanizada nos cuenta los antecedentes
en los que se basa esta demanda
una esperanza de Justicia una
organización de defensa de Derechos
Humanos la fundación cluny para la
justicia denunció a las fuerzas de
seguridad de Venezuela ante un tribunal
argentino la fundación invoca el
principio de jurisdicción universal y la
falta de garantías para que presuntos
crímenes de lesa humanidad sean
investigados y procesados en Venezuela
no estamos hablando casos aislados o no
se tratan de violaciones derechos
humanos aislados sino que hay una
creemos que una política de estado en
Venezuela hay una sistematicidad donde
vemos que no es solo una persona de
cometer los delitos sino que hay una
cadena de Mando donde se dan órdenes el
esfuerzo de la fundación creada por la
abogada de Derechos Humanos a Marc pluny
recibió el apoyo de amnistía
internacional
las víctimas que hoy han denunciado
crímenes de lesa humanidad han confiado
en Argentina sus esperanzas de Justicia
los tribunales argentinos tienen
jurisdicción constitucional sobre estos
crímenes no por el lugar donde fueron
cometidos o por quién sino porque dañan
a la humanidad en su conjunto Esperamos
que la justicia Argentina esté a la
altura del desafío y mantenga su
tradición histórica de juzgar y
sancionar a los responsables de estos
crímenes a todos los niveles y es que
Argentina ya ha aplicado con
anterioridad el principio de
jurisdicción universal tribunales de ese
país se han pronunciado en torno a
crímenes el régimen franquista en España
e investigan el genocidio contra la
etnia rojilla en miamar la Corte Penal
Internacional abrió una causa formal
para investigar presuntos crímenes
contra la humanidad durante el gobierno
de Nicolás maduro y la misión de
determinación de hechos en la ONU
documentó ejecuciones extrajudiciales
desapariciones forzadas detenciones
arbitrarias tortura y tratos crueles
cometidos en Venezuela desde 2014
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo American France 24 ustedes Les
agradecemos su sintonía los invitamos a
continuar con nosotros que ya llega a
Francia en foco feliz noche para todos
[Música]